quiero armar un puente
muchas veces en hispanoamérica no le
ponemos atención a la tecnología porque
esas cosas de otros
y lo que quiero que entiendo no es que
la tecnología es como mentar una
piedrita a un estanque entonces yo las
olas y olas y a veces es una piedra
y a veces es un meteorito
entonces la gente siente que huber es
pues una app que puede uno colocar en el
teléfono
y llega el cochecito y ya ya veces se
molesta un taxista
pero lo que quiero que entiendan es que
eres una piedra
porque el impacto que tiene über es que
hace muy sencillo que no pidas coche
y el coche es increíblemente caro porque
tienes que pagar el seguro tienes que
pagar el financiamiento tienes que pagar
el garaje tienes que pagar pues el
accidente etcétera etcétera y lo que
está empezando a pasar es que si manejas
menos de 16.000 kilómetros por año no es
sensato si vives en una ciudad usar un
coche particular y entonces el 22 por
ciento de los usuarios de uvero the left
o de todos los otros servicios
sencillamente no están comprando
automóviles
y qué es lo que va a pasar en los
siguientes década pues la siguiente
década vamos a tener automóviles
autónomos
el automóvil autónomo va a bajar el
costo de usar nuestros servicios
en 50% y en ese aumento no es sensato
comprar un automóvil particular
entonces qué es lo que empieza a pasar
en países como brasil o méxico o lugares
que tienen grandes empleos armadoras
autopartes pues que la venta de
automóviles particulares baja en un 80
90 por ciento porque porque los
automóviles empiezan a usar como los
aviones están en constante circulación
entonces una cantidad muy importante de
empleos puede empezar a cambiar de
manera fundamental por esa piedrita que
en total
no solamente cambia el negocio de los
autopartes esto cambia de manera
fundamental las ciudades pongamos a
pensar un edificio de oficinas típico la
cuarta parte la tercera parte de ese
edificio ese estacionamiento todo este
sentimiento empieza a desaparecer porque
llega el autor y cuando no existe
entonces el costo de una oficina por
metro cuadrado empieza a bajar el costo
de una vivienda por metro cuadrado
empieza a bajar el estacionamiento en
las calles empieza a desaparecer la
velocidad promedio de circulación la
ciudad empieza a subir entonces hay una
serie de cambios sistémicos
en la principal causa de muerte para
jóvenes entre 16 y 60 años que son los
accidentes automovilísticos hay un
cambio en el negocio de los seguros pues
ya no se van a necesitar seguros para
automóvil hay un cambio en los seguros
de vida porque desaparece una causa
importante de que te mueras entonces
esta piedrita resulta ser un meteorito y
lo que es muy peligroso para américa
para los hispanos por américa latina es
no entender que una tecnología ortogonal
que parece que no nos afecta nos va a
afectar de manera fundamental de
generarles un segundo ejemplo hace
algunos años fundé una compañía con
craig venter y james net que básicamente
tomó todo el código genético de una
célula y lo sustituyó por un código
genético completamente distinto
y eso lo que hace es permite programar
una célula para ejecutar funciones
entonces un poquito como lo que pasa en
mi teléfono con una serie de apps y este
maneja fotos y éste maneja mensajes y
éste maneja música y éste maneja el otro
eso es lo que podemos hacer con una
célula porque es tan importante esto
porque al poder programar células
podemos programar casi cualquier cosa
que sea orgánica entonces casi cualquier
cosa que se produce de manera orgánica
en fábricas o en campos lo podemos hacer
ahora en grandes piletas de sopita verde
como ésta
entonces aquí podemos fabricar gasolinas
y lo vamos a hacer conexión en una
gasolina básicamente neutral en uso de
carbón pero también en una serie de
industrias paralelas esto empieza a
cambiar de manera fundamental por
ejemplo si estás en el campo agrícola en
vez de producir tres cosechas al año
para sacar la proteína de la soja o el
aceite de palma o el aceite o la azúcar
o del maíz pues ahora lo puedes hacer en
células y lo puedes hacer una vez y otra
vez y otra vez produciendo diez a cien
veces más por hectárea de lo que
produces con agricultura tradicional y
lo mismo lo puedes hacer con ganadería
puedes fabricar hamburguesas de otra
manera que en el 2013 costaban
trescientos mil dólares
hace dos años costaban 30 dólares y hoy
cuestan 3 entonces son cambios
sistémicos que si estás en argentina si
estás en brasil si estás en mexico es
muy importante entender estas pequeñas
cambios en las piletas que generan la
tecnología que se esparcen por toda la
sociedad
tomemos entonces un inventario cómo
vamos a enfrentar esto en américa
latina'
qué es lo que vamos a hacer con qué
recursos manejamos estas cosas esa fue
una discusión que todo en brasil a hace
algunos años con miembros del gabinete y
llegué y les dije miren yo soy un pobre
mexicano quiero entender de ustedes que
son los maestros como lo hicieron para
ganarle a todo el mundo cinco veces a
todo el mundo
claro estoy hablando de fútbol
y bueno no pueden entender la energía
que viene este salón me llenaron todos
los pizarrones me dijeron lo explicaron
que los mejores entrenadores y que la
excelencia y la especialización y la
dignidad y el apoyo social y todo esto
después de 20 minutos y juegan y este en
esto de las escuelas primarias y
secundarias
cuál es estos principios nos siguen al
escoger a los maestros y al escoger a
los profesores y al escoger a los
alumnos
les meten mucho dinero les da un apoyo
social buscan los mejores emprendedores
hacen una selección nacional
y cuál es la consecuencia de tratar el
fútbol como una competencia mundial en
fútbol
y que corea trate a las escuelas como un
deporte de competencia mundial porque en
corea cuando tomas una prueba al final
de tu preparatoria eso determina si vas
a ir a la universidad
aquí universidad vas a ir y qué vas a
estudiar y es un sistema absolutamente
brutal si tiene un costo altísimo en
términos de vidas personales de toda una
serie de cosas pero también tiene una
consecuencia para el país porque
imagínense que están viendo no
imagínense están viendo un millón de
puntitos imagínense que son un millón es
ciudadanos entonces qué es lo que nos
pasa a nosotros
que pongo más o menos 726 mil de estos
puntitos generar una patente en eeuu por
parte de los mexicanos y los mexicanos
tomamos unos 635.000 brasileños tomados
137 mil chilenos
toma 56 mil españoles
como 3000 coreanos
como 2000 norteamericanos
y cuando uno tiene un índice de
productividad con estos diferenciales en
términos de creación de conocimientos
porque una sociedad se educa en
tecnología y la otra no
pues acaba viendo una diferencia de 150
veces y qué es lo que acabó pasando en
esta época donde los conocimientos se
empiezan a dominar la economía pues que
la economía de corea y de méjico
producían prácticamente lo mismo hasta
los mediados de los ochentas y ahí la
educación los conocimientos el generar
empresas como shenzhen en korea y no
hacer eso en méxico o en brasil o en
argentina tiene consecuencias de largo
plazo que ahora han llevado a un
diferencial de ingreso de 3.3 veces en
menos de una generación
tomamos uno de los grandes universidades
de américa latina- la unam más vieja que
harvard la unam se jacta porque solo
admite el 8% en un examen nacional pero
cuatro quintas partes de la gente que
entre la unam no toma el examen nacional
no compite a nivel nacional entra por
las escuelas afiliados a la unam
inclusive los carneros de ciencia
y hay gente que dice que debemos obtener
un pase automático
que todo mundo debería poder entrar que
no deberíamos hacer elitistas o que
apliquemos esa reglas a los limpiados
qué pasaría si nuestro equipo olímpico
de fútbol o de judo o de vélez o de lo
que quieran ustedes la quinta parte
entra por ser los mejores del país y
cuatro quintas partes centran porque no
se estudiaron una empresa de entrenador
y pueden entrar con calificación de 10
de 9 de 81 de 7 a una competencia
mundial
que vamos a hacerlo
nos entramos a la capilla de santo niño
de oro negro
esto no es una cosa que tenemos que
hacer a largo plazo podríamos por
ejemplo tomar los campos del tecnológico
de monterrey o de escuelas similares en
otros países y buscar al mejor 2% a los
que están 2 o 3 desviaciones de la media
del lado derecho de esta curva y
concentremos esos alumnos en un solo
campus y pongámonos a competir como
coreanos durante dos años
si estos alumnos se gradúan con un
diploma de libertad o de lugar una vamos
a tener dos o tres de las mejores
universidades del mundo en un periodo
muy corto de tiempo en méxico o en
brasil y en argentina porque vamos a
empezar a tratar a lo mejor que tenemos
como una selección nacional
y por qué importa tanto esto porque en
una época de conocimientos 55 gentes que
generaron voto
generan el mismo valor de mercado que
toda la gente que se levantó durante un
año a trabajar en 15 países de
centroamérica y el caribe
imagínense que todos los mañanas se
levanta la gente en honduras todos los
agricultores todo los taxistas todos los
políticos todos los poetas todos
trabajan sus días 12 horas diarias y no
genera el mismo valor en el país entero
de lo que genera 155 gentes que fundaron
whatsapp
estamos en una época donde podemos
construir economías grandotas con muy
pocas mentes pero estos aumentos tienen
que ser competitivos a nivel mundial y
las tenemos que identificar
y el problema de américa latina es que
obtenemos lo que celebramos entonces
ciertamente tenemos a grandes
deportistas y claro hay uno que otro
político que celebramos
lideratos no nos faltan
pero habrá alguna gente en américa
latina que no me puede decir de
inmediato quiénes son estos 3
que no sabe que el sol de ti que no sabe
quién es molina que no sabe quién es me
diste
y ese es parte de nuestro problema
porque los tres ganaron el premio nobel
en ciencias
los tres deberían ser nuestros héroes
los tres de unidos en nuestros modelos
esa es nuestra selección nacional
y atrás de ellos
hay miles y miles de jóvenes que salen
de michoacán que salen de oaxaca que
salen de pana que salen de todos los
partes más humildes américa latina y
compiten a nivel mundial en hardware en
carthage en action y no los conocemos y
no lo celebramos
entonces la idea que quiero
transmitirles
es que hay que entender y se lograr la
ciencia y la tecnología y la educación
y sobre todo hay que celebrar la
selección nacional de hosteleros
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]